David Boder: [In English] Wiesbaden...Wiesbaden Sept...Wiesbaden, Germany, near Frankfurt, September 25th, 1946. We have here a pec...special type of housing of displaced persons. The Jewish group is not located in the armory nor in the camp but is billeted by the UNRRA in private homes. We are going to interview now one of the members of this community. The interviewee is Dr. Leon Frim, a doctor of jurisprudence, who lives here as a displaced person. We are going to hear now from him personally.
David Boder: [In German] Also, Herr Doktor, wollen Sie mir sagen, wo sind sie geboren...
Leon Frim: In Lemberg [L’viv].
David Boder: Und wo waren Sie und was hat Ihnen passiert, wenn der Krieg angefangen hat.
Leon Frim: Als die Deutschen nach Przemyśl gekommen sind, wo ich Rechtsanwalt war, haben sie alle Juden in das Ghetto gesteckt. Alle Juden. Und das Ghetto war gehütet von den SS-Soldaten, so dass keiner hinausdurfte. Man konnte nur gruppenweise die Straßen überqueren, um sich zur Bauarbeit zu begeben.
David Boder: In welchem Jahr war das?
Leon Frim: Das war im Jahre 41.
David Boder: Beschreiben Sie ein wenig das Ghetto.
Leon Frim: Also, das Ghetto hat drei Seiten...drei Straßen gehabt, in welchen die wichtigsten Häuser Przemyśls [unverständlich] waren. In diesen drei Häusern wurden zusammengerottet alle 21.000 Juden der Stadt Przemyśl, welche verstreut früher in der ganzen Stadt lebten.
David Boder: Was haben Sie damals in Przemyśl getan?
Leon Frim: Ich bin meiner geistigen Arbeit entledigt worden, weil kein Jude Advokat sein durfte, und bin an eine gewöhnliche Arbeit gerichtet worden, also als gewöhnlicher Arbeiter.
David Boder: Aber was war die Arbeit?
Leon Frim: Ich habe in einem Bauunternehmen als Maler gearbeitet. Als, äh, der Monat Juli kam, hatte man schon laut davon gesprochen, dass es zu einer Aussiedlung kommt. Wir haben Nachrichten gehabt von anderen Städten, dass angeblich Juden in eine Gegend geführt werden, wo sie ihre Zwangsarbeit ausüben werden. Es hat sich aber dann als unrichtig und als Lüge erwiesen. Das war im Juli wurde...wurde das Lager entsiedelt von der SS-Mannschaft...und dann...
David Boder: War das eine deutsche Mannschaft?
Leon Frim: Ja, das war damals eine deutsche Mannschaft, deutsche SS-Mannschaft. Dann hat man die Leute herausgezogen aus ihren Wohnungen, die Alten hat man separat auf die Seite genommen, man hat behauptet, dass sie den Weg nicht...äh, also in diese Gegend, wo die Zwangsarbeit vollführt werden sollte, nicht aushalten werden, man hat aber nicht gewusst, was mit denen geschieht. Als alle schon auf dem Platz da waren, hat man Schüsse gehört, also und wir haben erfahren, damals gesehen, dass alle alten Personen unter einer Mauer erschossen wurden.
David Boder: Wieviel schätzen Sie waren das, wieviel Leute waren das?
Leon Frim: Damals waren, von den Erschossenen waren einige hundert, und ausgeführt aus Przemyśl waren damals nur so [unverständlich] 5.000. Das war die erste Aktion.
David Boder: Wo waren Sie und was ist ihnen passiert?
Leon Frim: Ich bin damals noch im Ghetto geblieben.
David Boder: Warum? Wieso?
Leon Frim: Ich bin auf diese Weise geblieben, weil nicht das Ganze zusammengefasst werden konnte, es wurde teilweise getan. Also, die Arbeitsfähigen wurden noch für eine Zeit gelassen, und äh, Schwächere, dann Frauen und Kinder wurden alle einwaggoniert...und sie wurden gerichtet über Nacht [unverständlich] in eine Ortschaft, welche Belzec genannt war.
David Boder: War dort in Przemyśl ein jüdisches Komitee, und was für eine Rolle hat das Komitee in dieser Selektion gehabt?
Leon Frim: Damals war [unverständlich] Przemyśl nur sogenannte, also, Judenrat. Judenrat. Also das hat, das Judenrat hat ausgeführt die Verfügungen der SS-Behörden, natürlich unter Zwang. Wenn das nicht ausgeführt würde, wird die, also, die jüdische Bevölkerung darunter leiden, weil wir damals noch nicht wussten, ob es in den Tod geht, auf jeden Fall auch die Mitglieder der...des damaligen Judenrates. Und es kam auch dazu, dass bei der ersten, äh, bei der ersten, äh Aussiedlung der Älteste des Judenrates, ich glaube er war damals Duldig, das war Duldig, Dr. Duldig, der ist erschossen worden. Dann...ist es zur zweiten Aussiedlung gekommen, und zwar...und zwar war es im Monat November. Damals hat man den zweiten Teil, ich glaube so 3.500 oder wiederum 5.000 ausgesiedelt, wo die haben denselben Los...dasselbe Los erfahren wie die vorherigen. Bei der zweiten Aussiedlung hat man meine Frau, meinen Sohn und mich, äh, noch im Przemyśl-Ghetto gelassen, und wir wurden vom Ghetto in ein Arbeitslager Przekopana unter Przemyśl geführt.
David Boder: Wie groß war Ihre Familie und wie alt waren Ihre Kinder?
Leon Frim: Meine Familie bestand nur aus meiner Frau, welche damals etwa 40 Jahre alt war, und meinem Sohn, welcher damals etwa 17 Jahre alt war. Also, damals sind wir in dieses Arbeitslager gekommen, und von diesem Arbeitslager sind wir in die Stadt jeden Tag zur Arbeit geführt worden. Meine Frau hat damals in der Kasernenküche gearbeitet, also in der Lagerküche. Eines Tages, als ich, äh, eines Sonntags nach Haus kam mit der ganzen Arbeitsgruppe, fand ich meine Frau nicht mehr im Lager. Da hat man mir gesagt, es war eine SS-Mannschaft, und hat alle älteren Frauen zurück ins Ghetto geführt. Ich war sehr darüber bekümmert, weil ich nicht wusste, ob meine Frau wirklich ins Ghetto kam. Als ich es aber sichergestellt habe, habe ich mit meinem Sohn besprochen, wir sollen meine Frau vom Lager herausbekommen...
David Boder: Vom Ghetto herausbekommen...
Leon Frim: Vom Ghetto herausbekommen, weil damals schon über weitere Aktionen gesprochen wurde. Es ist uns damals gelungen, und meine Frau, äh...welche ich, welche ich arische Papiere damals gegeben habe, ist mit der Bahn nach Lemberg gefahren.
David Boder: Wie haben Sie das arrangiert? Erzählen Sie mir die Einzelheiten.
Leon Frim: Eine Polin aus Przemyśl ist hinter meiner Frau gegangen, meine Frau ist bis zum Bahnhof damals gegangen, an dieser Stelle, wo wir gearbeitet haben, und am Bahnhof hat diese Polin meiner Frau eine Karte gekauft, und meine Frau ist damals nach Lemberg gefahren. Bevor sie nach Lemberg gekommen ist, weil sie schon nicht mehr im Ghetto war, und nicht auch auf unserer Arbeitsstelle sich befinden durfte, hat sie viele Nächte, ich glaube drei oder vier Nächte, in verschiedenen Kellern verbracht, ohne zu Essen und ohne zu Trinken, weil sie sich nicht damals hinaus zeigen durfte auf der Straße, wo die SS-Patrouillen patrouillierten, und wenn ein Jude einzeln auf der Straße aufgefunden wurde, wurde er auf der Stelle erschossen.
David Boder: Aber sie hatte doch arische Papiere?
Leon Frim: Die arischen Papiere hat sie erst von mir damals bekommen, als sie sich zur Bahn begeben sollte. Nach einigen Tagen habe ich durch diese Polin eine Nachricht bekommen, dass meine Frau glücklich in Lemberg angelangt ist, und...
David Boder: Wieso, ist diese Polin mitgefahren?
Leon Frim: Nein, eine Karte hat die Polin von meiner Frau bekommen, eine Postkarte. Äh, ich wollte mit meinem Sohne meiner Frau nach Lemberg nachkommen, und wir haben sogar Vorbereitungen dafür gemacht, um von dem Lager, äh, also zu flüchten.
David Boder: Haben Sie der Polin bezahlen müssen?
Leon Frim: Nein, der Polin habe ich damals nichts bezahlt, das war eine Freundin unserer Familie. Also, nach einigen Tagen bekam ich von der Polin eine Nachricht, welche sie von meiner Frau bekommen hat, und zwar, dass sie zwar gut untergebracht ist in Lemberg, dass wir aber mit dem Sohne absolut nicht nach Lemberg kommen sollen, weil dort schreckliche Sachen vorkommen. Dann sind noch solche zwei oder drei Nachrichten gekommen, und, äh, am 28. Dezember 42 ist die letzte Nachricht gekommen, und zwar sie lautete auf diese Weise, wie sie mir die Polin mitteilte: Weil ich keine Nachricht über meinen Sohn und meinen Mann bekommen sollte, ich weiß nicht, ob sie noch am Leben sind, äh, begebe ich mich von Lemberg nach Warschau, wie sie damals gesagt hat. Ich habe aber damals, äh, der Sache nachgeforscht, und habe erfahren, dass sie damals sich nach Przemyśl begeben wollte, das war, um zu erfahren, ob mein Sohn und ich noch am Leben sind. Das war die letzte Nachricht von meiner Frau, und bis an den heutigen Tag, trotz aller, vieler Nachforschungen ist es mir nicht gelungen, äh, etwas, äh, über sie zu erfahren, so dass ich jetzt beinahe, äh, gewiss, die Gewissheit besitze, dass meine Frau nicht mehr am Leben ist. Ich bin jetzt mit meinem Sohne dann im Jahre äh, 44, äh, 43 ausgesiedelt worden. Die Aussiedlung haben durchgeführt, äh, die SS-Mannschaft zusammen mit, mit östlichen Männern, welche damals auch in SS-Divisionen waren. Man hat uns in, äh, plombierten Waggonen nach Szebnie...
David Boder: Wie viele Leute in einem Waggon?
Leon Frim: In einem Waggon waren über 100 Leute.
David Boder: Bloß Männer?
Leon Frim: Es waren Männer und Frauen, so dass wir keinen Platz hatten zu stehen, und wir haben, wir sind damals beinahe erstickt, weil alle Öffnungen mit Brettern verschlagen waren und mit Draht, äh, also mit Stacheldraht, äh, versorgt. Erst in Szebnie hat man uns ausgeladen. Dort hat gewartet eine Mannschaft, und der, äh, also, unter Aufsicht dieser Mannschaft haben wir müssen im Laufschritt einige Kilometer ins Lager, äh, laufen. Unterwegs wurde eine Frau, wenn ich nicht irre hat sie Achtel geheißen, erschossen, weil sie nicht so rasch, äh, laufen konnte. Das war alles in später Nacht. Als wir im Lager angelangten ...
David Boder: Einen Moment. Sind Männer und Frauen zusammen gegangen?
Leon Frim: Ja, es sind Männer, Frauen, und auch, äh, beinahe unerwachsene, äh, Leute zusammen mit uns gerannt. Als wir, äh, also, sehr erschöpft ins Lager kamen, da hat man uns einer Untersuchung unterzogen. Und zwar, man hat uns angeschaut...
David Boder: Welches Lager [unverständlich]?
Leon Frim: Szebnie, Szebnie, das war ein Lager bei Jasło. Wir haben nicht gewusst, dass es ein Vernichtungslager war. Das war doch ein Vernichtungslager. Und zwar, äh, in der Nacht, als wir neu angekommen sind, hat man uns [unverständlich], und die dortige Mannschaft, und auch die, die Judenordner, das heißt jüdische Polizei[unverständlich] im Lager hat das Ganze geleitet, wir wurden dieser Untersuchung unterzogen, ein jeder hat sich ausziehen müssen, und alle hingeben, was er bei sich an wertvollen Gegenständen hatte. Mir wurde damals die Uhr abgenommen, mein Ehering, äh, und alles Geld, was ich besaß, ich habe nichts versteckt, weil uns angesagt wurde, wenn bei jemandem etwas gefunden wird, wird er an der Stelle erschossen. So tat man es auch mit einem, der versuchte, etwas zu verstecken.
David Boder: Wer war das?
Leon Frim: Den Menschen hab ich nicht gekannt, weil, äh, ich habe nicht alle persönlich gekannt. Man hat aber damals verlautbart, dass bei einem das gefunden wurde, ich glaube Geld oder sowas, welches er nicht gemeldet hatte, und dann wurde er an der Stelle erschossen.
David Boder: Haben Sie gesehen, dass man ihn erschießt?
Leon Frim: Nein, das habe ich nicht gesehen. Also, nachher hat man uns in eine Baracke, äh, in einige Baracken gesteckt, wo wir kaum Platz fanden, um nebeneinander zu liegen.
David Boder: Beschreiben Sie die Baracke.
Leon Frim: Die Baracke war eine Holzbaracke, und die, das [unverständlich] war, also das waren, das war so gedacht für viele Leute, das waren keine Betten, nur lange Bretter, und einer ist neben dem anderen gelegen, ohne sogar einer Strohunterlage. Wir haben so den Frühmorgen abgewartet, und frühmorgens wurde uns Kaffee verabreicht. Am ersten Sonntag hat man einen Appell zusammengerufen. Das war der erste Appell im Lager Szebnie. Alle Juden, also alle Insassen der jüdischen Baracken, wurden zusammengerottet auf einem Platz, es waren unser damals 3.500. Es waren Männer, Frauen und auch Kinder aus verschiedenen Gegenden, also nicht nur aus Przemyśl, aber auch aus anderen Städten, wie zum Beispiel Bochnia. Bochnia war sogar damals sehr stark verstreten unter den Insassen des Lagers. Man verlautbarte uns, dass ein jüdischer Fahrer...
David Boder: Ein jüdischer Rabbi?
Leon Frim: Fahrer, Fahrer, also das heisst Chauffeur, welcher den Wagen des Lagerführers geführt hat, also, äh, nach Ungarn mit diesem Wagen geflüchtet ist. Der, das Urteil des Lagerführers lautete, es müssten dafür, als, äh, Strafe, zehn Juden erschossen werden, und zwar zehn Männer und zehn Frauen.
David Boder: Aber das sind doch zwanzig.
Leon Frim: Äh, fünf Männer und fünf Frauen. Einer der Häftlingswärter, ich glaube es war ein SS-Offizier, ich habe mich damals in den Farben noch nicht ausgekannt, ist an uns herangetreten, und hat aus, äh, der Mitte der Stehenden diese wählen sollen, welche erschossen werden sollten. Er ist an uns vorbeigegangen und gesehen habe ich so eine Szene: Als eine Frau, äh, bezeichnet wurde als diese, die erschossen werden soll, hat sich eine andere Frau gemeldet als ihre Schwester, hat gebeten, man soll die erstere freilassen, man soll sie erschießen, weil ihre Schwester sei welche, äh, für den Tod gewählt wurde, verheiratet war und ein Kind hatte. Ein SS-Mann, der bei ihr gestanden, hat sie, als sie noch gesprochen hat, erschossen, und auch ihre Schwester, so dass eine Leiche auf die andere gefallen ist.
David Boder: Das haben Sie selbst gesehen?
Leon Frim: Das habe ich selbst gesehen. Dann hat man die weiteren Leute gewählt...
David Boder: Und wie hat das Lager gehießen?
Leon Frim: Das Lager hieß Szebnie, bei Jasło. Man wählte weitere Leute, und ich hab gesehen, wie man fünf Juden und weitere vier Frauen niederknien ließ...
David Boder: Fünf Männer...
Leon Frim: Fünf Männer und vier Frauen niederknien ließ...
David Boder: Also wieso vier, man hat ja schon zwei erschossen.
Leon Frim: Nein, also elf wurden zusammen erschossen, weil die Schwester um das Leben der anderen Schwester gebeten hat, hat man sie auch erschossen, so dass elf [unverständlich] waren. Dann ist einer der SS-Leiter an die Knienden herangetreten, hat ihnen befohlen, sie sollen den Kopf herunterlassen, und hat einen jeden von hinten einen, äh, Schuss abgegeben. Einer von denen, bevor er den Schuss erhalten hat, hat gebeten, man solle ihm das Leben, äh, schenken, weil er doch nicht geflüchtet hat, und er kennt nicht einmal den Menschen, der geflüchtet ist. Also er kann ja für einen anderen nicht, äh, verantwortlich sein. Da hat ihn der SS-Offizier geantwortet: Schweigen Sie, Sie Feigling. Also der hat, äh, sich gefügt und hat dann seinen Gnadenschuss bekommen. Und dieser eben hat nach dem ersten Schuss noch weitergelebt, hat geröchelt, so dass man ihm noch den zweiten, den dritten, den vierten und den fünften Schuss in den Nacken abgeben musste, äh, bis er endlich tot war. Die Frauen waren sofort tot. Das geschah an unseren Augen, zwei Schritte von uns. Also dann...
David Boder: Wie hat man das erklärt, dass er nicht von dem ersten Schuss, so nahe gefeuert, gestorben ist?
Leon Frim: Es war ansehend ein, äh, starker Mensch. Also er hat geröchelt die ganze Zeit...
David Boder: Geröchelt?
Leon Frim: Geröchelt, also so solche, unartikulierte Stimme herausgegeben. Und dann hat er mit der Hand noch nach dem Kopf nach dieser Stelle gegriffen, wo der Schuss fiel, so dass man sich gewundert hat, wieviel Lebenskraft in diesem Menschen da war. Seine letzten Worte vor dem Erschießen waren [unverständlich]. Das kann ich mich erinnern als wäre das gestern. Mein Sohn hat mich bei der Hand gehalten und hat die ganze Zeit gesagt, Vater, schau nicht darauf. Aber man hat schauen müssen. Weils nicht anders gegangen ist. Nach einer geraumen Zeit...
David Boder: Was heißt „man hat schauen müssen“?
Leon Frim: Weil, das geschah ja vor unseren Augen. Man hat nicht können das Auge abwenden, man war wie paralysiert, das haben wir zum ersten Mal in unserem Leben gesehen. Also, nach... Ich bin damals als Maler in eine neue Werkstätte gekommen, und zwar als Schriftmaler. Für... In einer Woche oder weniger habe ich gehört, dass wiederum ein Appell, äh, aufgerufen werden soll.
David Boder: Haben Sie denn nicht jeden Tag Appell gehabt?
Leon Frim: Nein, dort waren nicht jeden Tag Appelle. Wir haben sogar geglaubt, dass Appelle nur zum Schießen der Leute zusammengerufen werden, weil bei einem jeden Appell wurde wenigstens ein Mann getötet. Also, ein andermal hat man einen aufgehängt, so hängend ist er einige Stunden, also, in dieser Position ist er geblieben und hat gebeten, man solle ihn erschießen.
David Boder: Also man hat ihn bei den Armen aufgehängt?
Leon Frim: Bei den Armen hat man ihn aufgehängt. In Gegenwart seiner Frau und seiner Kleine. Und er hat gestöhnt, und hat gebeten, man soll ihn erschießen. Und er...
David Boder: Warum hat man ihn aufgehängt?
Leon Frim: Er hat angeblich beleidigen sollen einen SS-Mann. Ob es tätlich oder, äh, also wörtlich war, weiß ich nicht, nur hat behauptet der SS-Mann, dass er schwer beleidigt wurde von diesem Menschen. Ein drittes Mal hat man mich gerufen auf den Appellplatz. Wir waren sicher, dass da etwas geschieht. Man hat uns mit der SS-Mannschaft in schwarzen Monturen, das waren Ukrainer damals, umzingelt mit Maschinengewehren. Wir waren sicher, dass wir alle getötet werden. Es hat aber damals nur 440 Leute gewählt, um sie zu erschießen, das war das Kontingent damals. Also, mein Sohn und ich haben damals das Glück gehabt, noch weiter zu bleiben, wir sind nicht gewählt worden, aber wir haben schauen müssen, wie unsere Kameraden, die neben uns standen, auf diese Seite gehen mussten, welche dann auch einen, äh, camion [LKW]geladen wurde und in einen Wald geführt, wo alle die erschossen wurden. Nachher hat man von uns drei Leute gewählt, man hat denen nicht gesagt, wozu sie hingebracht werden wohin sie hingebracht werden, und die sind nicht mehr zurückgekehrt. Wir haben gehört, dass sie zur Verbrennen, zum Verbrennen der Leute verwendet waren und damit selber auch erschossen. Auf jeden Fall sind sie nicht mehr ins Lager zurückgekommen. Nach einigen Wochen, also es war schon zwei Monate unseres Verbleibens in Szebnie, hat man uns auf den Appellplatz gerufen. Man hat alle Erwachsenen durchsucht, ob ein Jude sich nicht versteckt hat, und auf diesem Appellplatz sind wir den ganzen Tag — das war im November — gestanden im Regen, ohne zu Essen, zu Trinken, müde... Da haben wir gesehen, dass wir von allen Seiten durch diese schwarz monturierten ukrainischen SS-Soldaten umzingelt waren. Es waren zwar keine Maschinengewehre gegen uns gerichtet. Wir haben vermutet, dass etwas Schlimmes vorgeht. Ich hab meinen Sohn getröstet. Und, äh, nach einigen Stunden haben wir gehört, dass nur die wichtigsten Handwerker, äh, welche noch im Lager benötigt werden, zurückgelassen werden, und, äh, als die Namen dieser verlesen wurden, habe ich zu meinem Erstaunen gehört, dass man auch meinen und meines Sohnes Namen als zweier Maler, die im Lager ihre Beschäftigung haben, vorgelesen hat. Also, wir haben uns auf diese Seite begeben, wo diese, die am Leben bleiben sollten, äh, sich versammelt haben.
David Boder: Nun ja, man hat doch nicht gesagt, dass man die anderen zum Tode auswählt.
Leon Frim: Nein, wir haben nicht gewusst, dass jene zum Tode gewählt sind, aber wir haben gewusst, dass sie irgendwo in ein anderes Lager, wie man uns gesagt hat, verschleppt werden sollen. Wir haben nachher erfahren, dass die alle nach Auschwitz hinübergeführt wurden und dort rücksichtslos in den Kaminen ihren Tod gefunden haben. Unser waren 120, darunter acht Maler, und unter den Malern war mein Sohn und ich. Wir sind am nächsten Tag nach, äh, dem Lager Pustkow hingebracht worden, unter Bewachung natürlich. Lager Pustkow oder sogenanntes Heidelager gibt es bei Debica. Dort hat man uns zuerst zur Desinfektion genommen, zur Desinfektion sind auch alle anderen, also zusammen 120 gegangen, und bei dieser Desinfektion haben wir selbst unsere Kleider aus diesen Gaskammern herausholen müssen. Der Ausgang dessen war dieser, dass ein Mensch dort, äh, also, vergast wurde zufälligerweise, weil er zu lang in dieser Kammer gestanden, und unterwegs ist er gestorben, auf den Augen seines Vaters, welcher Tapezierer war. In diesem Lager Szebnie haben wir, also mein Sohn und ich, zehn Monate lang als Maler gearbeitet. Wir hatten damals, wir waren ganz von der Welt abgeschlossen, das war ein nur jüdisches Lager, und in der Nähe von uns befand sich das polnische Lager. Wir sind nie zusammengefallen, nur einmal in der Woche, wo wir baden sollten, sind wir hinübergegangen unter strenger Bewachung in das polnische Lager, und nach dem Bade wurden wir zurück in unsere Baracken geführt. So verbrachten wir die Zeit, also den ganzen Winter und das Frühjahr.
David Boder: Haben Sie heißes Wasser zum Baden gehabt?
Leon Frim: Ja, zum Baden war heißes Wasser, aber, wenn, äh, die die Einrichtungen nicht klappten, sind wir manchmal gegangen ohne zu baden. Sehr dürftig waren wir bedingt mit der, äh, also, Bekleidung und mit der Wäsche. Man hat betrachtet, dass wir keine Läuse bekommen, nicht unseretwegen, nur, äh, wegen der, der, der SS-Mannschaft, dass sie sich nicht von uns ansteckt. Also...
David Boder: Nun, beschreiben Sie, wie sind sie geschlafen.
Leon Frim: Also, es waren dort zweistöckige Betten. Mein Sohn und ich, wir sind unten geschlafen. Es war ziemlich rein dort, weil wir die Reinlichkeit unseretwegen schon beobachtet haben. Wir waren froh, als wir nach den Arbeitsstunden in den Baracken eingesperrt waren, weil damals waren wir unter uns, wir durften damals lesen und sogar haben manche getrachtet, irgendwo eine Zeitung zu bekommen und so wussten wir, was in der Welt vorgeht. Die Nahrung war weniger wie dürftig. Also, äh, wir können nicht sagen, dass wir gehungert haben, damals, aber das hat kaum gereicht, um arbeitsfähig zu bleiben.
David Boder: Und für wen hat man da gearbeitet? Wozu war das Ganze nötig?
Leon Frim: Das Lager war für, weil, äh, Exerzierplatz oder sowas wir haben nicht gewusst wofür und wo, für wen wir arbeiten, es sind Bestellungen gekommen, das hat ein SS-Mann, welcher Lagerführer war und dieser Leiter der Werkstätten, der hat uns diese Bestellungen gegeben, und wir haben diese ausgeführt. Ich war damals als Arbeiter, nicht einmal als Meister beschäftigt, und, äh, am Sonntag hatten wir frei, Sonntag waren wir frei, also, Sonntag war zur Reinigung bestellt, wir haben saubergemacht, und manchmal haben wir uns sogar, das war zwei- oder dreimal, solche Abende veranstaltet, das waren Vorstellungen, jüdische Vorstellungen, also, wir haben es niemandem gemeldet, aber niemand hat es uns auch verboten. Weil das drinnen in den Baracken war...
David Boder: Hat man die Leute anständig behandelt, hat man jemand geschlagen?
Leon Frim: Geschlagen wurde man sehr oft. Also, ob es, äh eine, äh, also, eine Ursache zum Schlagen war oder nicht, das weiß ich nicht, ich hab vielmal gesehen, dass ein Jude geschlagen wurde, aber das war so ein gewöhnlicher Schauspiel, dass ich nicht einmal gefragt habe, warum man diesen schlägt.
David Boder: Hat man auch Sie misshandelt?
Leon Frim: Ich bin damals von niemandem misshandelt worden. Ich kann mich nur an einen Fall erinnern, der... Ein Jude namens Unger, glaub ich, ein junger Mensch, den ich nicht kannte, äh, ist an dem Tor gestanden, als, äh, Unterstützung der Bewachung. Das heißt, er gab acht, dass niemand, der Eintritt in das Lager hatte, in das Lager hereinkommt.
David Boder: Der nicht Eintritt...
Leon Frim: Der nicht Eintritt hatte. Er hatte auch das Recht, nicht hereinzulassen SS-Leute, welche gerade nicht die nötige Bescheinigung hatten. Das war schon knapp in unserem jüdischen Lager, deshalb ist ein Jude da gestanden. Der wurde verdächtigt, dass er, äh, es erlaubt hat, dass da im Lager jemand mit Schuhsohlen oder sowas gehandelt hat. Diese Tatsache ist festgestellt worden, er ist als schuldig, äh, von dem SS-Lagerführer anerkannt worden, ist in den Bunker gesteckt worden und man hat ihm zu verstehen gegeben, dass, wenn er sich nicht selbst den Tod, äh, macht, wird er, äh, denselben Los erfahren wie ein jeder, der in den Bunker hineinkommt, das heißt, sterben muss er. Am nächsten Tag hat man ihn gefunden mit aufgeschnittenen Venen.
David Boder: Was war dieser Bunker?
Leon Frim: Ich hab den Bunker nicht gesehen. Ich glaube es war eine Art Keller, also betonierter Keller. Ich war dort nie, also bin nie in Berührung damit gekommen. Das weiß ich nur vom Erzählen. Aber von weitem habe ich den Bunker gesehen und weiß, dass der Mensch nicht mehr zurückgekommen ist. Man hat ihn sogar von weitem gezeigt, die Tragbahre, auf welcher man ihn geführt hat, also die Leiche dieses verstorbenen Unger. Im Juli 44, ich glaube das war aufgrund der, äh, Kriegsvorkommnisse draußen, hat man das Lager liquidiert. Man hat uns einwaggoniert, zu 80 und zu 100 Leute in einen Wagen, und hat die Wagen abgesperrt, so dass wir nicht atmen konnten. Wir hatten kein Wasser, keine Luft, und die Fenster wurden, äh, dieser Viehwägen, in welche man uns geführt hat, hat mit Brettern, äh, zugeschlagen. Manche versuchten Löcher in der Wand oder in den Boden dieser Waggons zu machen, um Luft zu schöpfen. Viele sind unterwegs ohnmächtig worden, und an manchen Stellen, gleich hinter dem Bahnhof, äh, Bahnhöfen, wurden für einige Momente die Türe dieser Waggons geöffnet, dass die Leute ihre Notdurft verrichten können. Dann wurden wir wiederum in die Wagen gesteckt, und wiederum gehen wir. Nach zwei Tagen sind wir auf eine Station gekommen, wir haben nicht gewusst, dass es Auschwitz ist. Als wir dort waren, hat einer dieser SS-Wachleute, die uns geführt haben, hat uns gesagt, ihr werdet in einigen Minuten erfahren, was mit euch vorkommt. Wir waren damals gewiss, dass wir in Auschwitz sind, und jemand hat uns dann draußen angerufen, wir wissen nicht wer das ist, ihr seid schon neben den Kaminen. Wir sind nämlich, der Wagen, in welchem wir uns befanden, wir wissen nicht wo wir sind, ist auf dieses Geleise gefahren, welches in die Kamine führte. Da entstand unter uns eine Panik. Es war, wir waren so heiß, dass man ersticken konnte. Alle haben sich ausgezogen, weil es unmöglich war auszuhalten, das war nun Juli. Wir sind nachts dagelegen, viele sind ohnmächtig worden, darunter mein Sohn, weil er mich damals nicht erkannte. Man hat ihm gesagt, dein Vater lebt ja noch, hat er gesagt, nein, das ist nicht mein Vater, in der Finsternis hat er nicht gesehen und hat mich nicht einmal an der Stimme erkannt. Ich habe ihn angesprochen, und er ist dagelegen wie eine Leiche. Also, wir haben alle geschrien, Massenmörder, weil wir wussten, dass wir in einigen Minuten den Tod erfahren werden, und, über welchen man uns schon vielmal mitgeteilt hat. Also, wir sind so die ganze Nacht auf diesem Geleise gestanden, und haben nur Unterhandlungen gehört. Als man die Wagentüre geöffnet hat, hat man uns aussteigen lassen. Damals wurden wir geprügelt, warum wir nackt sind. Das war schon unter dieser Halle, wo man hineinging, um verbrannt zu werden, also...
David Boder: Vergast...
Leon Frim: Vergast zu werden, ja. Unter diesen Gashallen. Also, äh, man hat uns befohlen, wir sollen uns anziehen. [Stille auf dem Band] Und weil es im Waggon, im Wagen, so heiß war, dass es unmöglich war auszuhalten, und wir wollten dass, dass es mehr Platz war. Es war so ein Gemenge verschiedener Leiber. Wir wussten nicht, ob jemand tot ist oder ob er nur ohnmächtig ist. Damals haben von dem Waggon nachts herausschrien hat, haben wir uns nach verschiedenen Fragen gerichtet, wo jemand etwas finden konnte. Und wenn jemand noch etwas... [Stille auf dem Band] Dann haben wir erfahren, dass ein Unterscharführer, der uns geführt hat... [Unterbrechung]
David Boder: [In English] Wiesbaden, Germany, September the 25th, 1946. The interviewee is Dr. Leon Frim, doctor of jurisprudence, 47 years old, and we continue here from spool 156.
David Boder: [In German] Also, nun weiter. So waren Sie in Auschwitz.
Leon Frim: Ja. In Auschwitz hat man uns einer ärztlichen Untersuchung unterzogen. Mein Sohn und ich wurden als arbeitsfähig befunden. Hat man uns in eine Baracke geschickt, wo uns die Nummern eintätowiert wurden.
David Boder: Was ist ihre tattoo number?
Leon Frim: Meine tattoo number ist A.180 41.
David Boder: Kein Dreieck, nein?
Leon Frim: Nein, kein Dreieck. Mein Sohn hat dieselbe, nur die nächste Nummer gehabt. Als wir die Nummern schon bekommen haben, hat man uns zu Essen gegeben. Dann hat man uns zur Kleidungkammer geschickt, wo wir diese gestreiften, äh, Häftlingsmonturen bekommen haben.
David Boder: Hat man Ihnen die Haare abgeschnitten?
Leon Frim: Ja, die Haare hat man uns noch in Przemyśl zum ersten Mal geschnitten.
David Boder: Am ganzen Körper?
Leon Frim: Ja, nur am Kopf. Und dann zum zweiten Mal in Pustkow, also im Heidelager, dann wurden wir ganz rasiert, am ganzen Leibe. Zum dritten Mal hat man uns rasiert in, äh, Auschwitz, also vor dem Badengehen.
David Boder: Komplett?
Leon Frim: Ja.
David Boder: Also dann hat man sie doch nicht nur am Kopfe die Haare geschnitten?
Leon Frim: Nein, am ganzen Leibe. Und dann sind wir in diese Monturkammer gegangen. Dort haben wir diese gestreiften Monturen bekommen, Holzschuhe. Und haben wir uns draußen versammelt, sofort auf Wagen geladen worden, und in eine Ortschaft Gleiwitz geschickt. In Gleiwitz waren vier Lager da. Mein Sohn und ich, wir sind in das Lager... Mein Sohn und ich sind in Gleiwitz in das Lager Gleiwitz III geraten. Das Lager war gemauert. Dort habe ich in dem, in dem Keller eine Werkstätte bekomme und als Maler dort, als Lagermaler gearbeitet. Zu Anfang hatten wir...
David Boder: Und ihr Sohn?
Leon Frim: Mein Sohn hat zu Anfang mit mir gearbeitet. Außer der Schriftmalerei habe ich auch Kunstmalerei ausgeübt, und ich hab, war diese Dekorationen an Wänden, in dem Speisesaal, also, alle vier Wände selbst bemalt.
David Boder: In welchem Speisesaal?
Leon Frim: Das war Speisesaal der Häftlinge. War ein großes Speisesaal. Ich hab den Befehl bekommen, den Speisesaal mit Wandmalereien zu schmücken. Also, aus dem Gedächtnis habe ich solche vier große Bilder in Gleiwitz in diesem Speisesaal gemalt, und zwar, äh, Frühling, Sommer, Herbst und Winter. Dann ist eine Kommission gekommen und hat die Arbeit für gut befunden, und, äh, ich hab ein Päckchen Tabak dafür bekommen. Das war die Gratifikation für die Arbeit. Oft habe ich welche diese mit meinem Sohne bekommen, das war aber gewöhnliche Nahrung, wir waren aber damals zufrieden, weil es mein Sohn bei mir so ziemlich gut hatte. Eines schönen Tages hat ein SS-Mann entdeckt eine Ähnlichkeit zwischen meinem Sohn und mir.
David Boder: Die haben nicht gewusst...
Leon Frim: Die haben nicht gewusst, dass ich Vater und er Sohn ist. Als er, er hat mich gefragt.
David Boder: Hat man Sie denn niemals beim Namen zum Appell gerufen?
Leon Frim: Nein wir haben Nummern gehabt. Wir waren Nummern, nummeriert. Also, er hat mich gefragt, ob es mein Bruder sei. Ich habe ihm gesagt, das ist mein Sohn. Hab ich zur Antwort bekommen, dass es unmöglich ist, hier solche Zustände einzuführen, als wäre das ein Sanatorium. In einigen Tagen wurde mein Sohn von mir abkommandiert und zu schweren Arbeit gegangen. Habe ich den Lagerführer gebeten, man solle ihn wenigstens bei der Malerarbeit, äh, belassen. Und so war es auch, er war beim, beim Malen in den Minen oder sowas, als Lackierer bemüht. Er musste jeden Tag nicht weit zur Arbeit gehen mit allen anderen. So dass wir uns nur mittags und Abends gesehen haben. Wir sind neben, nebeneinander geschlafen. In Jänner 45 ist ein Befehl gekommen, das ganze Lager muss äh übersiedeln, Man hat uns, äh, befohlen die Baracke zu verlassen, man hat uns aufgestellt, und obwohl nicht ein jeder einen Mantel hatte. Mein Sohn hat einen Mantel gehabt, ich war ohne Mantel, mussten wir hinaus in die Kälte und dann haben wir etwas zu essen bekommen. Als wir unterwegs vier bis 6 Tage waren ...
David Boder: Aber, sie haben nicht im Speisesaal gegessen?
Leon Frim: Nein, nein draußen haben wir bekommen, diese, äh, Verpflegung für den Weg. Und vierzig zu Fuß aus Gleiwitz unter Führung der SS-Bewachung, ähm, also hinausgegangen. Ausgewandert.
David Boder: Hat die SS auch marschiert.
Leon Frim: Die SS-Mannschaft ist neben uns marschiert. Die Obersten aber, die sind in Wagen gefahren. Die Wachmannschaft hat sich immer abgewechselt, so dass wir immer andere Leute als Bewachung hatten. Wir sind aber unaufhörlich, äh, marschiert. Nur mittags haben wir am ersten Tag Rast gemacht. Dann haben wir von unseren Vorräten etwas gegessen. Ähm, meinem Sohne und mir wurde am ersten Tag das ganze, was wir zusammen genommen hatten an Nahrung, an Nahrungsmitteln gestohlen, so dass wir am nächsten Tag schon betteln mussten, bei anderen Kameraden damit sie uns ein Brot geben. So...
David Boder: Wo haben sie diese Nahrungsmittel äh bekommen, die sie mit hatten? [unterbrechend]
Leon Frim: Die Nahrungsmittel habe wir bekommen noch in Gleiwitz als wir uns auf den Weg machten. Ein jeder hat da glaube ich zwei Brot, zwei Leib Brot bekommen und etwas Margarine. Das habe ich am ersten Tag noch gehabt, als ich das dann weil ich müde war, an ein Fuhrwerk, welches äh Nahrungsmittel für die SS Mannschaft geführt hat, gelegt habe, habe ich es nicht mehr am nächsten Tag an Ort und Stelle gefunden.
David Boder: Ja, Sie waren müde, so müde, dass sie das kleine Päckchen nicht tragen konnten.
Leon Frim: Ähm, ja, also das war Winter. Wir waren schlecht gekleidet, haben den ganzen Tag marschiert und wir waren damals zu Märschen nicht trainiert, weil wir ja immer im Lager waren. Also, das war der erste Marsch, am ersten Tage am Abend waren wir schon sehr müde. Und ...
David Boder: Und?
Leon Frim: Und außerdem mussten wir die Wagen, welche nicht bespannt waren, auf den Wagen, also die Wagen haben wir selbst geschleppt, und auf den Wagen befand sich, äh, Nahrungs- äh, befanden sich Nahrungsmittel, und auch Kleidungsstücke überhaupt das ganze Gepäck der Bewachungsmannschaft. Das haben wir ...
David Boder: Wessen? [Unterbrechend]
Leon Frim: Der Bewachungsmannschaft.
David Boder: Hatten die denn kein Auto? Oder Automo... - Or Pferde?
Leon Frim: Unsere Kräfte waren ja billiger, da haben wir das geschleppt. Und mitgeholfen mit die Wagen, wenn es auch bergauf, also, zu schleppen, und wenn irgendjemand unterwegs nicht ziemlich tüchtig gearbeitet hat, hat er auch äh, wurde er auch geschlagen, von der Wachmannschaft. Also auf diese Weise haben wir beinahe ganz Schlesien passiert. Wir sind an verschiedenen Stellen gekommen [unverständlich] wie sich die Situation, wo sich die [unverständlich] wie sich die Situation darstellt. Manchmal haben wir auch schon gehört und haben gehört, dass die Befreiung kommt schon. Aber die SS-Mannschaft hat Weisungen von irgendwo bekommen, uns immer zu bringen ein Stück aus diesen Gegenden, welche ihrer Ansicht nach bedroht waren und unser Ansicht nach uns Rettung bringen konnte. Auf diese Weise sind wir marschiert drei Wochen.
David Boder: Sagen sie: Konnte man bei so einem Marsch denn nicht weglaufen? Nicht verstecken oder so?
Leon Frim: Unterwegs sind einige weggerannt. Es waren Fälle, dass sie erschossen wurden. Und manchen ist es gelungen. Weil ich meinen Sohn bei mir hatte, wollte ich das nicht probieren. Ich habe immer gedacht, wenn es mir bislang gelungen ist, mit dem Leben davon zu kommen, vielleicht wird es Gott geben, dass es sich zu rechte führen wird. Wenn ich allein wäre, hätte ich dem Rate meines Sohnes gefolgt, welcher mir immer sagte, wir sollen davon rennen. Es war schwer, wir waren ja umzingelt von SS-Leuten und ich war immer in einer Vernunft gefangen. Ich wollte nicht wegen dem Sohn und ich wusste, wenn ich es wäre, dann wäre es auch ein großer Schlag für ihn, also deshalb, habe ich es dabei beharren lassen, und ich bin den ganzen Weg mitgegangen.
Leon Frim: Auf diese Weise haben wir unterwegs kaum nur, auch nur an manchen Stellen etwas zu essen bekommen, Pellkartoffeln und gewaschen haben wir uns die ganze Zeit nicht, wir haben ausgeschaut, schlimmer wie die Tiere. Einer hat den andern nicht erkannt. Also verwachsen, verwildert, schmutzig, nicht gewaschen, ausgehungert, nicht ausgeschlafen. Wir haben manche Nächte, in, äh, nicht in, äh, in Scheunen, ja, verbracht, also, das war nicht deshalb, das wir nicht, dass wir nicht unter freien Himmel die Nacht verbringen, nur deshalb, dass wir nicht entweichen, hat man uns eingesperrt in verschiedene Scheunen. Uns hat man zusammengetrieben hunderte von Leuten von verschiedenen Gegenden, also nicht nur von unserem Lager, aber auch andere Lager sind dort zusammengetroffen. Wir waren in einer Scheune manchmal einige Tausend. Das war so sehr fadenscheinig, und da war eine Schlägerei, weil ein jeder sich um ein Stückchen Platz für die Nacht herumschlagen musste mit seinen Kameraden.
Leon Frim: Unterwegs, davon habe ich noch keine Erwähnung gemacht, wurden viele von uns erschossen und zwar: Wenn jemand zurückgeblieben ist, weil er nicht weiter gehen konnte, weil er ausgehungert war, müde und ganz erschöpft, dann wurde er ganz einfach niedergeschossen, und in den, äh, Seitengraben hineingeschmissen. Manche haben die Bewachungsmannschaft gebeten, sie sollen sie erschießen, weil sie sich nicht weiter bringen können. Bei manchen war es so, wenn er nur etwas zurückgeblieben ist, hat man, äh, behauptet, dass das ein Fluchtverdacht ist, und er wurde aus, äh, aus diesem Grund erschossen. Vor uns sind schon andere Lager vorbeigegangen und haben den Weg gezeichnet mit verschiedenen Leichen. So dass, als wir die Landstraßen passiert, äh, haben, sind, da haben wir in den Gräben viele Leichen in diesen gestreiften Monturen gesehen. Das waren lauter, nur die Juden, ausschließlich Juden. Weil nur die Juden marschiert waren. Wir, auf diese Weise sind wir gekommen in das Lager Groß-Rosen. In Groß-Rosen hat man uns in eine Baracke gestellt, gesteckt, welche noch nicht fertig war. Das war alles im Winter. Um in diese Baracke zu gelangen, mussten wir ein Weg passieren, welcher so fertig waren, dass das der Boden bis über die Knie, aber ganz aus wirklich bis kurz bis über die Knie war gereicht. Wir konnten nicht die Füße herausbekommen aus diesem Boden. Als wir in der Nacht schon in die Baracke gekommen sind, sind wir in Boden niedergefallen und so bis morgens gelegen. Am Frühmorgen hat man uns heraus aus der Baracke getrieben, auf einen Platz, dort haben wir, äh, zu essen bekommen, also Suppe und für unterwegs Brot und ein Stückchen Wurst.
David Boder: Wie groß war das Stückchen Wurst?
Leon Frim: Oh, das Stückchen Wurst war so groß, dass wir es auf einmal, äh, aufaßen. Es sollte einige Tage reichen äh reichen, weil wir noch einen weiten Weg vor uns hatten.
David Boder: Ungefähr wie viel war es in Gewicht?
Leon Frim: In Gewicht konnte das 10 Dekagramm sein, 100 Gramm, 100 Gramm. Vom Lager, von Groß-Rosen, hat man uns geführt. Also, die ganze Zeit unter Bewachung, bis zum Bahnhof. Ich hab schon damals abgefrorene Füße gehabt. Sie haben mich sehr geschmerzt und geblutet, ich hab Angst gehabt die Schuhe auszuziehen, die Holzschuhe, weil ich gewusst hab, habe, dass etwas mit den Füßen nicht in Ordnung ist. Ich konnte meinem Sohn nicht helfen und bin so, äh, unter großen Schmerzen weitergegangen. Ich trampelte auf einer Stelle, manchmal so schnell, wenn wir halt gemacht haben, dass mein Fuß zum, also, wenn das zugefroren ist, habe ich die Schmerzen nicht so gespürt, dass, die Schmerzen waren gelindert. Da bin ich einige Zeit gut marschiert, bis das aufgetaut ist, dann haben die Schmerzen angefangen. Ich habe schlecht angefangen zu marschieren, und mein Sohn hat mich die ganze Zeit gezogen. Ich habe immer gehört die Worte: Vater, Komm Vater, Komm weil, die geben schon Acht auf dich. Du bleibst immer zurück. Er hat Angst gehabt, wenn ich zurückbleibe, werde ich sofort erschossen. Man hat uns einwaggoniert in offene Wagen, auf der Station in Groß-Rosen und so sind wir vier Tage und vier Nächte ohne etwas zu essen oder zu trinken bekommen zu haben, in offenen Wagen unter Schnee, in Gewitter gefahren, bi s nach Buchenwald.
David Boder: Mit dem Gewitter, sie meinen im Schneegestöber, nicht?
Leon Frim: Ja, Im Schneegestöber. Wir waren ja nicht geschützt vor Schnee. Die einzige Nahrung war der Schnee. Einer hat von anderen den Schnee, herab-, heruntergezogen und auf diese Weise haben wir unseren, unseren Durst gestillt. Also als wir an der Station Buchenwald angekommen sind, hat man uns aussteigen lassen. Da haben wir uns erst vergewissert, dass wenigstens ein Viertel in den Wagen geblieben ist. Die waren voll Leichen. Die Dreiviertel sind noch ausgestiegen. Wir sind entlang des Bahndammes gegangen und unterwegs ist jeder, beinahe jeder Dritte ist umgefallen und hat sich nicht mehr gehoben. Die wurden nicht mehr erschossen, die haben so den Tod aus Erschöpfung gefunden. Und der ganze Weg war wie gepflastert von Leichen in diesen gestreiften Uniformen.
David Boder: Doch sagen sie, In Wagon, wo sie waren, Wie stirbt denn ein Mann vor Erschöpfung. Was sind die Symptome?
Leon Frim: Also, die haben sich gelegt, einer ist beinahe auf den anderen gelegen. Das waren so viele Leute, dass es unmöglich war, dass ein jeder sich setzen konnte. Also, man ist die ganze Zeit gestanden, wenn man sich gesetzt hat, ist man gesessen auf einem anderen. Da wurde man von jemandem geprügelt. Es war Nacht, Schneegestöber. Am Tag war es beinahe dasselbe. Wir waren schon keine Menschen. Wir waren jeder Moralischen entledigt, also, man hat sich herumgeschlagen mit den letzten Kräften und äh, also das lässt sich nicht ausdrücken, äh, diese Stimmung in welcher wir uns damals befanden. Ich bin nicht, äh, vorbereitet, auf diese Antworten und deshalb, spreche ich nur so von, also, ich kann das nicht so, so, literarisch nicht sagen.... [zögerlich]
David Boder: Ja, aber ich habe ihnen ja schon vorhin gesagt, wir suchen keine literarischen Antworten.
Leon Frim: Gut aber, es ist nicht, vielleicht nicht so zusammenhängend.
David Boder: das ist sehr....sehr...
Leon Frim: Also, als wir ins Lager, Buchenwald gekommen sind.
David Boder: Sehen wenn das alles so literarisch wäre, dann werden sich noch manchmal Leute finden, die sagen werden, ich habe es für sie aufgeschrieben. [Unterbrechend]
Leon Frim: Ach ja, also als wir in Buchenwald angelangt sind, hat man uns dort unter einer Baracke stundenlang stehen lassen, weil man behauptet hat, wir müssen zuerst desinfiziert werden. Auf diese Desinfektion haben wir drei Tage und drei Nächte gewartet.
David Boder: Wo?
Leon Frim: In Buchenwald draußen. Man hat uns in eine, also ich kann das nicht Baracke nennen, weil das nur Wände waren, ohne Dach. Das war eine un- äh beendete Baracke, welche kein Dach hatte und so auf dem schmutzigen Boden, welcher ganz nass war, sind wir gesessen, weil wir müde waren. Wir haben alle gebebt und gezittert vor, äh, Kälte. Und dann, äh, wir haben nur einmal täglich essen bekommen.
David Boder: Also beschreiben sie, was haben sie damals angehabt. Von der Haut an bis oben. Was haben sie angehabt?
Leon Frim: Damals haben wir angehabt noch die Kleider von Buchenwald. Also ich habe...
David Boder: Buchenwald? [nachfragend]
Leon Frim: Von, äh, Gleiwitz von Gleiwitz. Also ich hab eine Unterhose, eine Hose, eine äh Ziviljacke, welche mir einer geborgt hat und eine gestreifter [unverständlich]?
David Boder: Ein Hemd?
Leon Frim: Und eine Hemd
David Boder: Ein Hemd. Strümpfe?
Leon Frim: Strümpfe keine.
David Boder: Was für Schuhe?
Leon Frim: Äh, Holzschuhe
David Boder: Was für eine Mütze?
Leon Frim: So eine Häftlingsmütze war das.
David Boder: Die war woraus gemacht?
Leon Frim: Das war eine Stoffmütze so gestreift [unverständlich]
David Boder: Die Unterhose war woraus?
Leon Frim: Die Unterhose war eine Zivilunterhose.
David Boder: Aber ja, war es Flanell oder war es Baumwolle
Leon Frim: Das war einen Art Flanell, die war oft so, ich glaube, gestreift, das war speziell für Häftlinge, die war dunkelblau mit solchen weißen Streifen. Das war zivil, oder ich habe es nur Häftlingswäsche immer bekommen. Also mein Sohn hat eine, also auch Wäsche gehabt, dieselbe wie ich, auch Holzschuhe und einen Mantel. Als wir endlich zu unseren Stationen gelangten sind, nach drei Tagen und drei Nächten, also da hat es so ausgeschaut. Man hat uns ganz nackt, ausge-, ausgelassen ...
David Boder: Wo?
Leon Frim: Ja in einem Raum, in diesem Baderaum, dort hat man uns alle glatt rasiert, am ganzen Leib. Dann zogen wir in einen, in eine, also in einen solchen Pott...
David Boder: Beschreiben sie, womit hat man sie rasiert? [Unterbrechend]
Leon Frim: Das waren solche elektrischen Maschinen
David Boder: Ja, Dann hat man bloß die Haare abgeschnitten, das waren keine Rasiermesser.
Leon Frim: Nein, nein, nein, das waren solche Haarmaschinen,
David Boder: Schermaschinen?
Leon Frim: Schermaschinen, ja, Elektrische Schermaschinen, aber bis an dem Leib haben sie alles glatt geschoren. Dann sind wir in so einem, in so einem Fass, also einer nach dem anderen gegangen, in welchen eine Art Desinfektionsmittel sich befand. Also, das hat so in den Augen ge-, ge-, gebrannt, dass man dann nicht die Augen öffnen konnte.
David Boder: Mussten sie sich untertauchen?
Leon Frim: Ja, ein jeder musste sich einige Male untertauchen. Dann nach dieser Taufe, äh, sind wir alle unter diese Dusche gegangen. Ein jeder hat sich rein gewaschen und von dort hat man zuerst diese, äh, also Wäsche bekommen. Das war schon ganz gewöhnliche, zerrissene, ein Zivilhemd. Und ich habe gebeten, man soll mir und meinem Sohn auch eine Unterhose geben, aber das haben sie abgeschlagen.
David Boder: Also beschreiben sie, was haben sie angehabt?
Leon Frim: Wir haben nur Zivilhemden bekommen und nichts mehr. Dann sind wir in die Kleiderkammer gegangen. Dort hat man mir eine zerrissene, dünne, blaue Arbeiterhose gegeben. Am Knie war sie, war sie ganz zerrissen. Ich hab sie angezogen, am nackten Leib, so dass mir die nackten Füße, also durch diese zerrissene Stelle sichtbar waren. Und eine Häftlingsbluse, gestreifte Häftlingsbluse. Mein Sohn hat bekommen, eine Häftlingshose und Häftlingsbluse. Und beide haben wir Häftlingskappen bekommen. Ich hab gebeten, dann hab ich mich zu einem deutschen Kapo gewendet, er soll mir erlauben, dass wir wenigstens diese Schuhfetzen bekommen, hat er mich behetzt mit den Worten: Du Jude. Zu Ende, bei Ende des Krieges wirst du schon Fetzen bekommen. Also, du kannst ohne Fetzen herumgehen, hat sich der Jude da erlaubt. Und ich hab das nicht mehr wiederholt.
David Boder: Erklären sie; Er war ja ein Häftling selbst.
Leon Frim: Er war ja ein Häftling selbst, Aber die Häftlinge die uns bewacht haben, haben uns manchmal so schlimm behandelt. Und vielleicht noch schlimmer wie die SS Mannschaften. Die waren ja bekannt für viele Fälle.
David Boder: War dieser Kapo ein Jude? [unterbrechend]
Leon Frim: Nein das war ein Deutscher. Dann waren wir sicher, dass wir endlich in eine Baracke kommen. Um endlich nach vier Tagen solches Stehens im Draußen, unter ein Dach zu kommen. Also, weil aber kein Platz da war, hat man uns noch einen Tag und noch eine Nacht draußen stehen lassen. Wir haben gewinselt vor, vor, vor äh, vor Schmerzen, weil es war ja draußen schließlich äh Winter, wir haben uns nicht wärmen können, haben nichts zu essen gehabt, und so Not und, allein in Wasser äh damals war der Schnee auf welchen wir gesessen sind in dieser unvollendeten Baracke aufgetaut. So verschmutzt haben wir am nächsten Tag einen Lärm angefangen weil es uns schon egal war, wann man uns verbrennt. Abseits haben wir gesehen das [unverständlich] Krematorium. Mit dem waren wir schon, mit einem Schornstein. Mit dem waren wir schon bewandt, und es war uns schon egal, ob man uns verbrennt oder nicht. Also...
David Boder: War das in Buchenwald?
Leon Frim: Das war in Buchenwald. Eines schönen Tages, also nach vier Tagen des Aufenthaltes hat man uns in der Nacht zu einer Baracke geführt. In der Baracke haben wir kaum äh einen Ort gewusst, wo wir liegen können. Es wurden von unter uns einige als Chargen erkoren, als sogenannte Buxenälteste/Buchsenälteste. [Anm. des Übersetzers: Mit Chargen bezeichnet Frim Häftlinge, die als Barackenälteste bzw. Buchsenälteste die Aufsicht in den Barracken hatten.] Jede Buchse umfing zwanzig oder dreißig Leute. Einer von uns, wurde zum Buchsenältesten erkoren, zum Buchsenältesten gewählt. Aber sie haben sich auf diese Weise benommen, so wie die, wie die Kapos. Ein Buchsenältester, das war, glaube ich, ein Tschech, damals. Als ich ihn gebeten habe, er soll mir erlauben, oben nicht ganz unten zu liegen, am Fußboden, weil der Fußboden ja ganz schmutzig war, hat er mich an den Kopf geschlagen. Hat er mir gesagt, dass ich meine Stelle nur ganz unten finde. Weil ich müde war, also ich hab mich...
David Boder: Waren denn auch andere mit ihnen zusammen?
Leon Frim: Ja, es waren auch andere zusammen. Die Stärkeren haben sich einen höheren Platz genommen. Mein Sohn und ich, wir waren schon so müde, dass wir kaum auf den Füßen stehen konnten, wir waren zufrieden, dass wir schon unter einem Dach sind. So sind wir gekrochen unten, unter die unterste Schichte also ganz unten am Boden, so dass man den Kopf nicht heben konnte, man musste nur in der liegenden Position, äh, verbleiben. Es war keine Luft, nachts, wenn man aufstehen wollte, da, da hat man kaum Gelegenheit gehabt, ohne Schlägerei mit dem Nachbarn herauszukommen. Also am ersten Abend wurden mir die Schuhe gestohlen und als ich am nächsten Tag dies der Buchsenaufsicht meldete, hat er mich ausgelacht.
David Boder: Wurden Ihnen die Schuhe von den Füßen gestohlen oder haben sie sie mit reingenommen?
Leon Frim: Nein, wir haben die Holzschuhe unter unseren Füßen gelassen. In der Sicherheit, dass niemand sie stehlen kann. Als sie gestohlen wurden, habe ich diesen einen, der schon lange Zeit in Buchenwald war. Er ist auf einen Haufen gegangen, wo schmutzige Abfälle waren, hat dort zwei andere, äh, Holzschuhe gefunden und hat sie mir gebracht. Die waren ganz [unverständlich] und ich habe die Füße, welche ganz wund waren, weil sie abgestorben waren, hineingesteckt in diesen [unverständlich].
Leon Frim: Also so saßen wir da drei oder vier Tage. Nach dieser Zeit hat man uns zu einer ärztlichen Kommission gerufen. Wie der Ausgang der Kommission war, wusste ich damals nicht, aber nach weiteren zwei oder drei Tagen, habe ich erfahren, dass mein Sohn und ich als Invaliden in die Invalidenbaracke kommen. Das war die Baracke Nummer 65. Also, weil wir die ganze Zeit keine Nahrung bekamen, und zwar es war, es wurde nur einmal täglich fertige Nahrung verabreicht. Ein Tag vorher wurde beim Appell, welchen wir dauernd von circa drei Stunden bis tief in der Nacht gestanden sind ohne Unterbrechung geschweige denn ein Mahl. Also hat man uns dann die Marken verteilt und für diese Marken hat man am nächsten Tag, äh mittags, also einmaliges Essen bekommen können.
Leon Frim: Einmal ist es meinem Sohne passiert, dass jemand ihm die Marke gestohlen hat. Dann hat er am nächsten Tag, als er schon an der Fuhrwagen, das Essen zu holen war, bemerkt dass die Marken nicht da waren. Da hat er für 24 Stunden überhaupt nichts gegessen. Ich war schon damals nach dem äh Mittagessen und musste leider von einem Kameraden Essen betteln und ihm dafür am nächsten Tag ein Stück von meiner Ration geben.
Leon Frim: Also damals hat sich mein Sohn angefangen schon zu beklagen, dass er Schmerzen in der Gegend von der Niere hat. Also als wir in die Baracke Nummer 65 gekommen sind, hat er nur eine Nacht dort übernachtet, und zwar auf der Seite der Kranken und ich war noch auf der Seite der Gesunden. Am nächsten Tag hat er Fieber bekommen. Aber er hat es mir nicht sagen wollen und ich ...
David Boder: Beschreiben sie die Baracke ? [Unterbrechend]
Leon Frim: Es war, ähm, an einer Seite sind die Kranken gelegen [Unverständlich für ca. 30 Sek.]
David Boder: Wie ging es ihnen?
Leon Frim: Ich mit meine abgefrorene Füße bin auf der Seite der Gesunden, weil jemand sagen konnte, dass man eine Operation durchführen kann und dass es werden kann. [Unverständlich für ca. 30 Sek.]
Leon Frim: Also am nächsten Morgen, habe ich von den Kameraden erfahren, warum ich, wenn ich melde, dass mein Sohn krank ist. Und ich hab unter Tränen meine Kameraden gebeten, sie sollen mich in Ruhe lassen. Ich habe denen gesagt, ich will mich von meinem Sohne nicht trennen und wir waren die ganze Zeit zusammen. Wie [unverständlich] zusammen gehören. Da hat mich einer angeschrien und hat mir vor die Augen gestellt, dass der Tod ja auch uns trennen wird.
David Boder: Wer hat das gesagt?
Leon Frim: Das war ein Häftling, ein jüdischer Häftling. Das hat mir eingeleuchtet. Ich hab mich zum Arzt gewendet, der war ein Jude. Der hat meinen Sohn untersucht und hat mir damals [unverständlich]äh, die Sicherheit genommen. Ich hab gebeten, man soll ihn hier draußen liegen lassen, [unverständlich]. Das haben sie mir nicht erlaubt. Ich habe ihn nur hinausbegleitet und ich habe gesehen, wie sie ihm etwas gegebt [sic] haben. Dann habe ich noch zum letzten Mal...
Leon Frim: [Unverständlich für ca. 20 Sek.] ... Ob er eine Meldung von ihm hört. Er hat mich jeden Tag getröstet. Es war ein Pole. Hat mir gesagt, dass er keine Meldung hat. Also, die Sache steht so, dass mein Sohn noch weiter noch in Gewahrsam bleibt. Als ich eines Tages, nach acht Tagen dem Blockältesten gemeldet habe und gefragt, ob mein Sohn schon genesen ist, da hat er mir erklärt, polnisch, in polnischer Sprache: Leider, ich muss dir, muss dir, äh, mitteilen, dass dein Sohn gestorben ist. Dann bin ich zusammengebrochen. [Frim weint fast] Er hat mich aufmuntern wollen. [Frim spricht sehr langsam]
Leon Frim: Ich bin zurück auf meine Stelle gegangen, weil ich schon damals tot erschöpft und krank war. Meine Füße waren, es wurde immer schlimmer. Hat schon zu bluten angefangen, dass ich nicht einmal zu den Appels hinausgegangen bin. Ich hab niemandem gesagt, dass ich in den Füßen Tot habe. Ich hab mich nur auf meine Schwäche berufen und deshalb hat mir der Blockälteste erlaubt, die Baracke nicht zu verlassen, weil er gesehen hat, ich bin nicht im Stande, mich auf den Füßen zu halten. Eines Tages hat einer meiner Kameraden gemeldet, dass es nicht gut, in der Gegend von meinen Füßen riecht. Da hat man mich untersucht und man hat mich zwangsweise in das Revier genommen. [Anm. d. Ü.: Mit Revier wurde die Krankenstation für die Häftlinge in den Konzentrationslager bezeichnet.] Dort habe ich erst etwas erfahren wollen, über meinem Sohn, aber niemand hat mir Auskunft geben können. Dort bin ich zwei Wochen gelegen. Die ärztliche Hilfe war schon zu spät, so hat mir dieser behandelnde Arzt damals gesagt. Dass ich mich vernachlässigt habe, dass die Blutvergiftung schon über das Knie gegangen ist, und da ist nichts mehr zu machen. Ich bin da so gelegen und der Gesundheitszustand hat sich dennoch von sich selbst angefangen zu verbessern, das hat sich immer zurückgezogen, so dass der Arzt hat gestaunt und hat mir Besserung beschieden ...
David Boder: Wie das hat geheilt?
Leon Frim: Die Wunden haben angefangen zu heilen. Und, der, äh, dieser schwarze Fleck, der schon über dem Knie war, ist immer blasser geworden. Ich hab können schon auf Füße herunterkommen. Dort sind sehr viele damals gestorben, in diesem, in dieser Baracke, welche direkt in Buchenwald war. Jeden Tag hat man sehr viele Leichen herausgeschleppt. Ich war in der chirurgischen Abteilung. Da waren weniger Leichen da, aber in der anliegenden, in der anliegenden Abteilung waren lauter Innenkranke, also Lungenkranke und auch Magenkranke. Die sind haufenweise gestorben. Eines Tages kommt ein tschechischer Arzt zu mir, welcher mich behandelt hat und hat gefragt, ob hier im Saal sich Juden befinden. Wenn sich hier welche befinden, sollen sie sich unter die Decke verstecken. Als einer gesagt hat, warum, hat er gesagt, morgen werdet ihr Antwort wissen, jetzt versteckt euch. Also, wir alle Juden haben uns versteckt.
David Boder: Wo?
Leon Frim: Äh, hinter der Decke. Wir waren in den Buchsen so dicht nebeneinander, dass es unmöglich war, einen zu finden, wenn man so nur vorbeigegangen ist.
David Boder: Das heißt im Revier sind mehrere in einem Bett gelegen?
Leon Frim: Das waren keine Betten, das waren lange Pritschen. Also, die waren geteilt in solche Abteilungen. In einer Abteilung, in welcher z.B. zwei Personen hätten liegen können, sind fünf oder sechs gelegen. Also, wir sind einer neben dem anderen so gelegen, dass wir uns nicht wenden konnten. Und alle haben, einer hat abgeschnittene Zehen gehabt, ein anderer war an einer anderen Stelle verwundet, das waren ja Leute nach den Operationen. Und ich habe mit den Füßen zu tun gehabt und die haben Angst gehabt, dass wenn sich der Eiter vermehrt, ich nicht einem anderen schaden. Da waren Fragen über mich, dass man auch darunter bleiben musste. Also nach dieser Nacht, wo man uns hieß sich zu verstecken, waren wir am frühen morgen sehr beunruhigt, wir haben aber niemanden etwas gefragt. Da hat man schon aber gehört, Schüsse von der Nähe. Wir haben vernommen, dass schon die amerikanische Armee sich uns nähert. Und am elften sind die Amerikaner. ..
David Boder: Wann?
Leon Frim: Am elften, äh, April ist die amerikanische Armee zu uns gekommen und hat uns damals gerettet. Also, ich kann mich erinnern, den ersten Amerikaner, einen Tankisten, der in unsere Baracke gekommen ist und hat uns das berichtet. Und damals wissen wir, dass wir in Gottes Händen sind. Wir haben gehört, dass die SS-Mannschaft zurückgezogen sind. Wir haben immer weiter die Schüsse gehört. Wir haben nur Angst gehabt, dass die Deutschen zurückkommen. Ein trauriger Abend war für uns, der Abend vom nächsten Tag, als wir erfuhren, äh, die traurige Nachricht von dem Tode, des Herrn Präsidenten, äh, Roosevelt. Wir waren wirklich damals sehr missgestimmt, sehr betroffen, als wir, äh, wussten, dass wir ihm verdanken, dass wir am Leben damals geblieben sind. Also, nach einigen Tagen, hat mich schon, äh, das amerikanische Armee Militär in ein Zimmer. Man hat mich in bessere Unterkünfte gebracht. Das war in ein Hospital, welches eingerichtet wurde in der SS-Baracke. Dort haben wir bessere Nahrung, bessere Wäsche bekommen.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes Spool 157. At, äh, Wiesbaden, Germany, September 25, 1946, Dr. Leon Frim, who will conclude on the next, who will conclude with this report on the next spool of Illinois Institute wire recording.
David Boder: Wiesbaden, September 25, 1946 in a colony of displaced persons, who do not live in a camp but in private homes. We will continue from spool 156-157, with the report of Dr. Leon Frim, a lawyer from a Polish, from Przemyśl from Poland. Poland?
Leon Frim: Poland.
David Boder: Poland.... [In German] Also weiter.
Leon Frim: Äh ja,
David Boder: [Unverständlich]
Leon Frim: Wir sind in bessere Baracken gekommen.
David Boder: Die Kranken oder alle.
Leon Frim: Alle, alle Kranken wurde in Unterkünfte, in bessere Unterwäsche gebracht. Also in die SS Bracken, das waren bessere Baracken und dort bin ich schnell zu Gesundheit gekommen. Als ich schon so ziemlich gesund war, als ich schon aufstehen konnte, hat man mich überführt nach, äh, Frankfurt, und weil da kein Platz war, nach Wiesbaden, wo ich noch dort im städtischen Krankenhaus war und als ich das städtische Krankenhaus verlassen habe, war ich noch eine kurze Zeit in einem, äh, äh, Sanatorium Taunusheim, wo ich, äh gänzlich genesen bin.
David Boder: Wer hat das städtische Krankenhaus bedient?
Leon Frim: Das städtische Krankenhaus hat bedient, also, die städtische
David Boder: Die deutschen? [Unterbrechend]
Leon Frim: Ja die deutschen Ärzte.
David Boder: Wie haben die sich dann benommen.
Leon Frim: Die haben sich sehr gut damals uns gegenüber benommen. Sie, also auch ... war gut, die Bedienung, die ärztliche und sonstige Bedienung. Die im Sanatorium Taunusheim.
David Boder: Das waren dort christliche deutsche Ärzte und christliche Schwestern.
Leon Frim: Ja, das waren christliche deutsche Ärzte und christliche Schwestern.
David Boder: Die haben niemals mehr Reden von Antisemitismus gezeigt?
Leon Frim: Nein, nein, niemals haben wir etwas von denen erfahren, das, äh, an, an Antisemitismus erinnert hätte.
David Boder: Nun wollen sie mir Herr Doktor sagen, also was tun sie jetzt hier?
Leon Frim: Also, damals als ich, ähm, gesund wurde, waren von uns einige zwanzig hier in Wiesbaden. Das waren mehrere Leute, die dieselbe Laufbahn durchgegangen sind, wie ich. Wir hatten erfahren, dass hier wieder einen ziemlich große jüdische Gemeinde war. Wir haben uns, äh, genähert, den Kreisen, die äh, also, an der Spitze der Gemeinde damals gestanden sind. Und wir haben hier eine jüdische Gemeinde gegründet. Zuerst war die Gemeinde geleitet durch die Frau Gutmann, das ist die Witwe von einem, äh, Rechtsanwalt aus Wiesbaden und dann wurde ich als, äh, Vorsitzender der jüdischen Gemeinde in Wiesbaden gewählt. Es waren Wahlen Anfang Jänner für das Jahr 1946. Und die Gemeinde wird jetzt von mir mit Unterstützung eines Komitees aus vier Leuten bestimmt, äh, geleitet.
David Boder: Nun sagen sie mal, haben sie die Absicht, hier in Wiesbaden zu bleiben?
Leon Frim: Nein, ich habe nicht die Absicht hier zu bleiben. Ich bin ja nach Deutschland zwangsverschleppt worden. Es war nie meine Absicht nach Deutschland herzukommen. Und ich könnte hier nicht bleiben, schon allein aufgrund dessen, was ich hier Schlechtes erlebt habe. Also nach diesen Erlebnissen, kann ich nicht in Europa bleiben. Die einzige Lebensmöglichkeit für mich ist auszuwandern. Da ich keinen Verwandten hier habe. Meine Frau, wie ich gesagt habe und mein Sohn sind umgekommen und ich nur Verwandte in Amerika habe, habe ich dieselben aufgesucht und ich mache seit April schon Anstrengungen, um nach Amerika hinüber zu kommen. Ich habe einen zweiten Beruf und zwar bin ich Kunst- und Schriftmaler und kenne auch die, äh, also, den Beruf als building painter, das heißt...
David Boder: Ausmaler?
Leon Frim: Nein, das, äh, Gebäudemaler.
David Boder: Nun sagen sie mal, wo sind ihre Verwandten in Amerika?
Leon Frim: Meine Verwandten leben in New York. Einer ist, äh Doktor Frank Teller, Dentist.
David Boder: Zahnarzt?
Leon Frim: Ein Zahnarzt jawohl. Ich hab auch seine Adresse und könnte sie ...
David Boder: mh?
Leon Frim: Und dann habe ich zwei Tanten. Eine die Schwester von meiner Mutter, die heißt Carla Stuch.
David Boder: Wo wohnt die?
Leon Frim: Die wohnt auch in New York City. Die hat zwei Töchter, das sind meine Cousinen. Und dann hab ich eine Tante, die heißt, äh, Regina Burker ich hab die Adressen von all den Personen.
David Boder: Sagen sie doch mal, nach welcher Quote gehen sie denn nach den Staaten?
Leon Frim: Man hat mich hier auf die polnischen Quota aufgenommen, obwohl ich doch geboren bin in Österreich. Ich bin geboren in Lemberg, und Lemberg war Österreich damals. Ich bin auch bei der Österreich-ungarischen Armee gewesen, habe im Jahre 17 und 18 bei der Österreich-ungarischen Armee gedient.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes the interview with Dr. Frank, äh with Dr. Leon Frim, doctor of jurisprudence, 47 years old, who lives now in Wiesbaden, how he says temporarily, is head of the Jewish community.
David Boder: [In German] Äh, arbeiten sie hier etwas, verdienen sie hier etwas?
Leon Frim: Nein, ich bekomme keine Entlohnung dafür. Das ist nur, nur ehrenamtlich.
David Boder: Und sie werden von der UNRRA unterstützt?
Leon Frim: Ja, die ganze Gemeinde wird von der UNRRA unterstützt und wir verteilen es gleichmäßig unter alle Mitglieder der Gemeinde.
David Boder: [In English] Aha, this kind of a corporate is an arrangement, äh, Wiesbaden, September the 25th, 1946. At the home of the new Jewish community, äh, the Illinois Institute of Technology Wire Recording.